[Music]
the thing with the the folks who
consider themselves transhumanists is
this this
weird understanding of evolution
and to them they really
hate the fact that evolution is this
weird unguided
blind process that's kind of fumbling
its way through history doing the
survival of the fittest thing and
hopefully ending up with
us
here they take that almost offensively
they think evolution is bad and what
they want is they want designer
evolution
they want to take the reins they want to
control the trajectory through which the
future human and the future body will
look and feel like
and then here's the funny thing you you
ask a transhumanist
hey man
take a chill pill
like why do you think
that you have the ability
to take the reins of evolution and
they'll turn around and they go well
evolution created intelligence
so that i could take the reins of
evolution
and you go wait wait a minute your
problem with evolution that was a blind
unguided process that kind of fumbled
its way to intelligence and humanity and
now you're telling me there was a plan
yeah that something somewhere was
guiding this thing to the point at which
and now kurzweil can go all right we'll
take it from here darwin we'll uh we'll
see where we can we can go from
here and and what i find
kind of odd about that whole thing is
that
transhumanists will sit there and go we
are becoming gods
and i'm like you're becoming a thing you
don't even believe in
[Music]
so
how do you know that's gonna actually
work out
that issue that we're
constantly struggling with when we ask
this
being human
question which is
are humans separate from nature or do we
do we come from nature because
if we say we come from
nature we kind of then make the argument
that the coming from nature peace is the
justification
for human intervention into the next
stage of what we're going to become
yeah
it's like uh any human intervention into
human biology must be natural because
we're of nature and we're making these
decisions so therefore it's come from
nature and you sit there and go okay
fun
but
is that
something necessarily that
that um
that we should be using as the guiding
principle
for
how and why and when we're going to
design
this stuff because essentially what i'm
trying to say is it used to be the fact
that that
the body and environment
was the thing that defined
what humanity
would become that's the kind of thing
that would control the destiny of
humanity
and now these guys are going hey
humanity
that thing that should control the
destiny of environment
and body and that's how we end up with
ideas of the anthropocene you know it's
the human age we are affecting the
environment through our activity and i
don't know about you but
how's that working out
and then they want to go and do that to
the body you have to go
let's pump the let's pump the brakes
here a little because the transhumas
community what do you really want to do
when you when you get them in the bar
afterwards go find out in sandberg he's
a he's a fun drinking buddy and you get
them in the bar afterwards and you
scratch them a little bit and you find
out what they're really interested in
and it turns out they're interested in
fixing things
and it's not fixing things as in
repairing things
it's fixing things as in
hey this like
human thing that i've got right now here
in the 21st century i kind of like this
and i want to fix this like fix it in
space and time
and you see that express i mean usually
it's straight white guys saying this but
they say they want this kind of way in
which they're operating fixed in space
and and time and you see that reflected
in the sorts of technology that they're
developing so the longevity technology
the sorts of technology that are going
to allow us to live hopefully ad
infinitum
as is the goal
that stuff's really about taking you at
around 30 years old
and just holding that space and time
you know biologically that's a great
place to be how do we
load a bunch of drugs onto the human at
that point in time the point at which we
are um
as they perceive it most uh
biologically kind of set for the world
and continue that and infinite and then
you've got the chronic crownix guys
these are the guys who want to freeze
everything
they literally want to go hey this thing
let's not wave goodbye let's go
yup we want more of that please let's
stick us on ice you know they literally
want to freeze a moment in time and
extend that into the future as if this
21st century life is the thing that is
worth preserving
and then you've got the mind uploading
guys who are the
best guys to talk to because i just
think it's mad
and they want to upload their minds into
computers and they want to live in
virtual environments that look when you
ask them very similar to the world in
which they're living now
but they have slightly more money a
faster car and they're going to live on
that server rack
hedonistically until the end of time and
let's face it if we do have a energy
crisis those guys are the first guys
we're switching off the the guys and
the guys in the um the server rack
but you've got to give transhumanists
a little bit of credit
because the wonderful thing about
transhumanist is at least they're techno
positive
you know at least they believe there is
a future
you know and that's kind of a that's
kind of a fun place to be in that's
that's kind of a fun place to play in
because the opposite
well the opposite is nihilism and the
opposite is accelerationism
you know what let's just accept our fate
roll over hope the ai comes in replaces
our intelligence and turns the world
into some form of weird plastic glob in
which ai is now the dominant form of
intelligence and i don't know about you
but that doesn't sound great
i don't know maybe it does maybe for
some people they're like like hey yes
and and and
part of the
motivations for some of these
trajectories
are
again
this
fear
of what might
come next
this fear of what might replace us
and that fear is is best encapsulated in
the
weird character that is elon musk
and elon wants to create this thing
called neurolink you know what elon is
scared of is the fact that we're not no
longer going to be the dominant form of
intelligence and the dominant form of
intelligence is going to be some form of
a
i
so how do we deal with this form of ai
well we enhance our human brains to deal
with the speed and complexity of the
digital environments in which ai will be
a better and more efficient worker
inside of the system that we generated
and created in the first place now the
ironic thing is like a week ago elon was
like we're going to create tesla ai so
i'm like
in terms of self-fulfilling prophecy
this guy's creating the problem and the
solution which by the way is great in
terms of marketing
you know you create the supply and the
uh and the
and the demand
and we got to those tricky words these
words that always kind of reappear
when we have these sorts of
conversations especially at the
institute for our own ideas
which is i guess
the environment we find ourselves in
you know the environment we find
ourselves in today is a very
technologically mediated environment
it's a technologically mediated
environment empowered by capitalism
we're looking at this thing as a threat
to our jobs and we're going any form of
advantage that i can get actually sounds
like a good idea to me
but the problem is
or at least the the thing we forget is
that we created that system in the first
place
you know so we created that system and
then we're re-engineering ourselves to
exist better in a system that we created
it's like sending a convict to prison
and they come out and they're more
efficient convict
you know it's the same it's the same
sort of thing
and and what happens then is that these
tech environments they end up weakening
human resilience we start devaluing this
whole being human thing
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas